Ladies and gentlemen, welcome to the SMC engine.
So in this brief video, and in the following videos,
there are some things that I want to discuss, share,
and give you my overview on.
Starting with why the SMC engine in the first place,
what is it, why is it important,
and ultimately how it's gonna help you
become more profitable or closer to profitability
if you're not already there.
I'd like to start by saying that the SMC engine
wasn't something that was created as a product.
It wasn't something that was supposed to be
going out to the public.
No, not all.
In fact, the SMC engine was something
that we developed internally to help me trade better.
Me and my team looked at my trading, my trading performance,
and this is something that I do very frequently,
and I ask myself, how can I make my trading more efficient?
How can I make my trading better?
And a lot of the times that comes with maybe more data analysis,
maybe categorizing higher probability setups
and things of that nature.
But in this instance, it came with,
how about my actual process?
How about my actual execution?
I found that on many occasions I was spending far too long
simply just performing standard routine analysis.
Not to mention that I noticed that a couple of times
I've deployed executions
when actually maybe I shouldn't have deployed executions
because I didn't spot some things.
Maybe I misread a structure point,
something of that nature,
and it's happened to me a couple of times.
And so it became prevalent that a solution to this issue
could quite easily be if we were to automate the process.
And so we started with structure,
because structure was the thing that consumed the most time
and was the easiest to get mistake.
And then we incorporated fair value gaps and order blocks
and session timings and liquidity points
and previous days highs and lows
and previous weekly highs and lows and directional bias.
And it came this all-encompassing indicator
that solves everything.
Now, I'm personally not a huge fan of indicators,
especially lagging indicators like the MACD
or things of that nature that don't really give you
any relevance to actual price
or what's going to happen there,
simply just lagging indicators of things
that have happened in the past
that really and truly have no indication
of what's going to happen in the future.
This isn't an indicator.
This is something that helps you execute better.
It's something that helps you with consistency and accuracy
and repeatability in your process.
And that's ultimately why it was created.
It was created by me, for me.
And then after, you know,
I've taught now probably a few thousand traders.
And although I was giving some traders the rules
and everything, I've taught the market structure.
I've maybe taught you market structure
and still you had issues, you had concerns,
you had doubts, you had questions.
You would still do things wrong.
And it dawned on me, why not release this to everyone else?
I mean, why not?
Ultimately, it's gonna be as helpful to you as it is for me.
And so that's why we decided to launch it.
And so that's what makes this different.
Many other indicators out there that you will see
have been created simply as a product to ship to you,
not created by a trader,
not something that actually helps a trader trade better.
And that's the big difference.
And so, yeah, the SMC engine is mind-cated for me
that I'm kind of open-source and allowing you to license
for yourself in hopes that it helps you trade better,
more accurately, more consistently,
remove doubt and give you more confidence
in your trading and your execution.
So that is what it is.
It incorporates all of my SMC concepts.
My actual rules.
That's another thing.
This is built on my actual rules.
And we'll go into that a little bit deeper
as we go into each individual video
that I wanna cover about each indicator
that's built inside of this one engine.
And so, over the next few episodes or the next few videos,
I'm gonna be relatively short videos.
I'm going to go into each and every component
of the indicator, how I would use it if I was you
and how I personally use it.
My settings, what I look for,
and then I'll tie everything together at the end
with a couple of examples of how simply allowing the indicator
to do a decent amount of my decision-making for me
enables you to get better executions more consistently.
So that'll forever do.
This is the SMC engine.
I really hope you enjoy it.
And let's dive into the first concept
which is market structure.
After that, we'll look at order blocks
of value gap liquidity and trade executions.
But for now, market structure.